so I get to have the fun of asking the
questions to this really great panel
with 3 i'd like to point out really
different points of view steve's venture
capital funding cool new ideas Astros
running probably one of the most
inventive labs but i think is it fair to
say managing a lot these days maybe
still there inventing and christina's
she's in the lab making the future
happen though the future is the theme
and so I want to start out by asking our
panelists to look back now cuz Back to
the Future came out 30 years ago I was
going to ask him to look back 30 years
and then I realized that all of you in
the audience weren't even in existence
30 years ago and that wouldn't mean
anything so we're just going to ask you
to look back maybe 10 years and maybe up
I'll start with you Steve name one thing
that didn't happen that you were sure
was gonna happen ten years ago um I know
you're gonna cool call me but I still
didn't prepare a thought hmm there's a
bunch ten years is tough cuz there have
been so many mistakes that I'm trying to
timestamp them so during the g1 no okay
well i thought amazon was gonna be an
anachronism and totally like made
obsolete by distributed federated
personalized systems I thought Netflix
would fail because clearly video is
going to come over the Internet not
these dvds they were mailing at the time
so these industry transitions like a
company that starts in one area but
expands or pivots or grows I just didn't
see those coming and I think I was maybe
at the tail end of being wrong about
nanotechnology and that rate at which it
would impact the world and how it would
and whether the term meant anything to
anybody but me and a few geeks like me
so that was a whole section mistakes
getting up to two thousand five sectors
so Astro you get the flip side what what
did you predict that is happening what
you get right
I was Steve I think it's it's more
interesting I mean I'll answer your
question I'll pick something but I want
to start with one or two things that
I've totally got wrong the one the one
that sticks in my mind I think of this
all the time because i have this mantra
at x about how almost all of my ideas
are wrong how all your ideas wrong all
of our ideas are wrong all most all the
time it's how we claw through all the
piles of ideas that we have to find
those gems that's the real trick and the
thing that i use to remind myself all
the time how wrong i can be is i
remember seeing the first phone about 10
years ago that a camera on it and I just
thought people are not going to take
pictures of their phones and even if
they did there's no way that they're
gonna be like obsessed sending pictures
to their friends it's like the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I was really
sure that that was not going to make it
I just remember very viscerally being
certain about that this is six good
humility muffin so was there something
that sticks in your mind that you got
right that you could see the future ten
years ago I think that so my background
is artificial intelligence and ten years
ago was a so-called AI winter and we are
out of that winter now and that was one
of the things I was incredibly confident
about because AI has been on this very
predictable sort of exponential increase
in its abilities and that people were
saying AI is dead or that it's never
going to actually accomplish anything
really never change that trajectory so
that was one of the things where I felt
like yeah we'll we'll see and in fact AI
has continued to make really steady
progress in a bunch of areas like
machine translation and speech to text
and computer vision and robotics and a
bunch of the areas in which it's just
continued to churn out benefits over the
years so I feel like I was right about
that okay and Christina something that
you couldn't have even imagined didn't
think about didn't think it was going to
be right or wrong but it's happened and
just changing the world biggest surprise
well um
i guess i would say let me just say two
things so something that I didn't even
imagine people would want to work on
beyond sort of fantasy and movies that
is not necessarily here yet but people
are seriously working on is
de-extinction right and and again it's
not that we've achieved that yet but you
know people are inching closer to that
right and people can kind of see this
happening with different with with
different creatures and animals and you
know it just wouldn't have even entered
my mind that that would be something
that we'd want to spend our time doing
the other thing though that is now here
that I that I wouldn't have predicted or
thought about is the idea of cloud
laboratories within biology right so so
really now you know thinking about
outsourcing um you know our experiments
and the way that we we do experiments
and examine things to companies where
that can be more systematized would not
have been something that I would have
even thought you know was possible them
or that there was even really a market
for so now let's turn to the future
Steve what's the coolest thing in the
pipeline Oh what time frame like right
now cool or you call it oh god it's all
of the place so the high-level
observation would be that when I started
in this business of investing starts 20
years ago was all in a few industries of
software semiconductors and biotech and
we didn't do biotech at the FJ so is
software sending doctors and variants
computing Teutonic self felt the same
and today it's like a whole variety of
industries that are treating transform
because of deep learning machine
learning techniques so everything from
rockets and drones and robots and
satellites that used to be really bad
industrial businesses they're not
becoming softwares country businesses so
in every one of those sectors it's kind
of recurring theme of how they're doing
it using off-the-shelf hardware from
cell phones repurposed in new
interesting ways and and that's exciting
and then closer to proceed in this area
of focus the whole revolution of
learning going on in life sciences and
how that percolates back to IT in
general like how do we build complex
systems how will we build these a eyes
of the future I think will be informed
by the way biology has done it but does
an existence proof and metaphorical
inspiration for how do you iterate on an
algorithm and compound intelligence over
time or complexity over time I think
those are the metaphors of the future
for how we do engineering I'm an
interview once I can people here okay
raise your hand in the back if it's a
good question it's okay hand is okay
good that's rare for me all right yeah
thanks ya know cuz this morning it was
tough so thanks for the check in and so
I think that field that excites me most
is biology the technique is machine
learning and deep learning across all
fields and then up comes that leads to
all kinds of moving things like
satellites they'll observe the earth
every day and broadband everywhere on
the planet via satellite and building
new life-forms that do interesting
things building organs for transplant
that are you know i'm not going to
trigger the immune system there's just
like probably 18 thousand different
student projects that would have seemed
like science fiction even five years ago
so astro can i ask you that question how
you just did I mean obviously there are
specific things that I can't answer but
one of the things that excites me which
is related to what Steve said is when i
look at the commonality across a lot of
the things that we're doing at x i
noticed that a lot of the projects are
both non-traditional in being robotics
but in fact actually our robots so we're
trying to get the other four and a half
billion people who don't have a good
internet connection today an internet
connection via a network of
stratospheric balloons but in fact those
balloons have to do a lot of sensing
they have a lot of actuation they can
rise and fall they're trying to pick the
winds that they grab and cause
themselves to sail to keep themselves
into useful places so if you have
sensing you have computation and you
have actuation in the very general sense
your robot our airborne wind turbines
are actually this shift from a huge
amount of steel to mechanically solve a
problem to essentially a very small
tether and a super hard control system
problem which is essentially bringing
robotics much more centrally to this
issue of generating energy our cars the
self-driving cars are kind of the poster
child for non-traditional robotics
ourself flying vehicles for package
delivery are very centrally sort of
robots
so in the sense of robots as walking
mechanical people i don't know how fast
that's really going to change the world
but i see a lot of these issues about
bringing techniques from machine
learning for mechanical engineering from
ways of embedding intelligence into
products as an alternative to making
them mechanically safer or mechanically
cheaper I see that as a very general
thing that we're going to be able to do
over and over again to solve problems in
the world that's cool um given this
revolution that's going on all the
changes Christina you work in a lab you
do your research how do you choose from
that whole menu of really exciting
things what to focus on and what what
you do so I think the first thing for
any of us is to really ask yourself
right ourselves what are we passionate
about right and what do we want to be
doing because you know if you're gonna
when you when you think about what
problems you want to work on you know
and what type of world you want to live
in there are many different routes to
take but you want to choose something
that you're going to want to put your
whole self and your whole sort of heart
body and mind into so that's the first
thing I think that really drives that
decision you know the second thing when
i think about problems that i want to
work on is you know I and especially you
know operating within an academic
environment I mean we are at least I
think our role is to not just think you
know two to five years into the future
our role is to think sort of 1020 years
into the future we should be doing
things right that are going to build the
foundational technologies right in
advances that then you know eventually
we'll move on into industry so I think
we want to look you know 10 15 20 years
into the future and ask ourselves what
are the big problems we see what type of
world do we want to live in and what you
know what is either the foundational
research or the applied research that we
want to focus on that we believe is
going to sort of make an effective
transformative changes in the world
around us right and then you pick what
problems you want to work in
and you dig in and the great thing about
working in an academic environment is
you have so many people around you to
work with that are going to bring their
creativity and spirit into it and take
things in entirely you know in
directions you couldn't even imagine and
you have to be able to give them the
freedom to do that Steve how do you
think policy is going to play into the
future innovations we're talking about
here that government policy yeah gosh
it's kinda like the Hippocratic oath you
first do no harm I guess comes to mind
does that mean you don't work on things
no I almost okay whatever clarify that
no no no so our companies interact a
policy a lot that we rarely if ever bet
on policy swinging our way with
approximately the exception of
autonomous vehicles where we don't know
how it'll happen but it just seems so
compellingly obvious that all vehicles
be autonomous an electric in the future
and will marvel at the present day that
we let people slaughter each other and
Rosen I'm one of those high-risk
category kind of people myself and so
you know that inflames me wait so we
know that's the future but but in
general that's saying the energy clean
tech investments that we made we only
never count on policy making the
investment work and so we generally are
pretty you know hands off it becomes of
that now government can play a big role
obviously in sponsoring projects whether
it's NASA helping spacek sket it start
or you know a big loan to Tesla
obviously at a critical juncture there
have been really important moments but
rarely is it one of them company picking
that's the rare model usually asino and
SF grants and government grants to
universities that are the bread and
butter of how we see government helping
the tech world and policy we just kind
of hope they don't make anymore you know
that's wishful thank you why no I just
kind of like try to keep my head low and
hope they don't bat down we we've had
sort of the opposite experience at X
which is we're trying to pick things
that we want to fix about the world
whether it's cars that drive themselves
or you know the contact lenses that we
built for monitoring people's bodies
putting a computer and sensors inside
contact lenses so you know whether it's
the FAA or the FCC or the FDA
a or the Fish and Wildlife like we've
had to talk to all of them in our
wildlife well for our airborne wind
turbine yes like there's no part of the
government the national highway traffic
safety administration that we haven't
had not just to visit once or twice but
like pretty much go live with them but
our experience has been that if you wait
until you're done making something and
then you go stand in front of them and
you say is this okay and you don't
really mean is this okay you mean this
will be a complete meltdown in my life
and life of lots of other people if you
say anything other than yes because
you're not going to get a straight yes
then you don't get the straight yes and
then you come away feeling like these
people are against innovation which I
don't think it's fair to them because
they're trying you know in an ideal
world regulators would have a membrane
that prevents all the bad snake oil from
getting through but let's all the good
innovation go through really fast but of
course you can't tell ahead of time
what's the snake oil and what's the good
stuff and I think they do a pretty
decent job our experience has been if
you go to them several years before
you're done and you say this is what
we're working on what do you think
here's the goal that we have this is
actually the problem that we're trying
to solve and we're not hung up about our
solution because it's not done we're
actually really hung up about solving
this problem in the world and the
regulator's universally are like excited
about the fact that we're trying to
solve problems for people and then they
can engage with us in a creative process
of saying great how do we help you to
get these things done so it can be safe
for everybody and you still don't feel
like you know you're being stymied by us
so I think it depends how you go about
it I agree we would never bet on
regulations changing but then again we
almost always bet that regulators can
work with us to change in ways that are
going to be necessary in order for the
world to be a better place I love the
optimism of that answer having been
quite a few years going back and forth
with Washington I can't quite be that
optimistic but I'm gonna subscribe I'm
going to subscribe because it's the
right way to do it no absolutely I want
to switch the topic now because
this room is filled with students ah and
I'm anticipating that you three might
have different views for on this but I'd
kind of like your thoughts on how do we
educate the engineer of the 21st century
what's the view of a broad education
versus you know should we just become
Stanford tech I mean thirty percent
thirty six percent of our students are
graduating in engineering let's just let
why not all of them um and well yeah
what what do you think is important
about uh what one learns in college and
carries forward from it and so maybe I'm
going to give it over to Christina for
the first try on that one as the the
educator who's actually in the classroom
teaching and then I'll go to Stephen
after um first and foremost you know and
especially if we're talking about
engineers uh I think in and I know
number of my colleagues also believe
because we have a lot of conversations
about this that one of the most
important things we want to teach our
students is how to choose what to work
on right because you are going to go on
and continue to learn right and continue
to add to your knowledge but being able
to kind of make decisions about this is
something that is you know something
good for me to invest my time in this is
something that is not these are the
implications of this particular
technology that I might develop you know
here's the ethical implications your
societal implications here's
implications in terms of access and how
will that affect the world around me
those are really important things to
learn right and we're to spend your time
on so we try to structure a lot of our
classes to bring those elements in right
that's the first thing second thing I
actually do think it's important for for
students especially now right to be able
to work in teams interdisciplinary teams
right and leverage each other's
expertise and also be really good and
effective at communicating with another
with each other and handing off tasks
and and being able to pass off knowledge
in that way so that's another thing that
we try to bring into our classes and the
third thing that I will say which is
just sort of very broad in general and
this came up in a earlier discussion we
were having today is you know I think
many people would agree
and I might be biased in this but you
know many people would agree that that
there really is sort of a revolution
happening within the field of biology
right especially with sort of advances
that we see in genetics genomics the way
that we treat DNA is information and and
and I think traditionally biology has
been almost sort of a niche right many
of us many engineers you know only take
biology don't have to take a biology
class right we might have to take a
physical class we might have to take a
chemistry class but there's not a broad
even basic literacy in biology and I
think we really need to change that and
and treat it as something that everybody
should be broadly literate and to really
be able to move you know into this next
realm of technological advances that
we're going to see and that will also
allow us to think about how we bridge
biology with computer science with
information science right with mechanics
I mean etc and allow us to move across
disciplines and I think that's very
important in something out that is a
deficiency right now and how we train
students so a stroke you agree with her
I think that that's exactly the right
set of stuff that we look for how great
are they at communicating how great are
they at learning how practiced are they
at working in groups so that's the stuff
that we should be training people to do
I'm actually not a huge believer that
you have to pick what it is you're going
to be an expert at now study that really
hard and then go out and shop that
expertise for the rest of your life you
know the bad news is that the stuff that
you're learning now is going to be
fairly irrelevant in 10 years seriously
I mean just get prepared for that it is
going to be irrelevant yet remember that
when you're doing your homework sets
tonight but the good news is that the
skill of learning things quickly
figuring out how to understand first
principles and be able to reconstruct
your knowledge even after you forget
ninety percent of it later those skills
are critical for the rest of your life
and picking up those through those
homework sets matters actually way more
than the actual knowledge that you're
taking in I just had someone sit down
with me who used to be a tank battalion
commander his first job after
being a tank battalion commander was to
come to X and he was doing field ops for
Project loon the stratospheric balloon
project now a few years later he is
literally designing the balloons he had
no background in any of that before but
he's fantastic at it and he was saying
well maybe I'm it's getting time to like
hand that over my team has really
developed and I'd like to kind of go
back to the early stages and do some
more stuff and I said why don't you just
join another field ops team that worked
for you the first time just go get some
mud on your boots jump into a team even
though you're really expert at these
things now they won't know it and you're
probably going to develop a new set of
expertise that has nothing to do with
balloon design by the time you're done
so don't get wound up about it just take
that quick step back and you'll rock it
forward again and I think the same is
true for everyone in this room that if
you plan for static stability you're
going to be really frustrated but if you
can build the skills of dynamic
stability it's going to be awesome Steve
I want to amplify that and totally agree
it's a framework for what you're saying
is if you believe and I think you should
if you're close to science and
engineering that we're in an era of ever
accelerating technological change you
can think of Moore's laws want to pity
me of that then a corollary is the
lifespan of any given idea company
technology product you name it is going
to become more more ephemeral and so
you're a career your life of lifelong
learning becomes all the more imperative
right that process learning how can I
learn how can I engineer better how can
I pivot to something new from what I've
done are critical skills so translating
to what that means to here today think
about methodologies of enjoy the
scientific method you have methodology
of traditional engineering you have
these unusual things like deep learning
machine learning that are closer to an
evolutionary algorithm and learning more
about that in biology and how it infuses
all fields will be important so if I
could take what Christina said I'd say
everyone here no matter what you're
studying to learn a little bit about
biological systems and how they work and
a little bit about computer science will
be almost like the connective tissue
between almost anything you want to do
in your life because I think those are
the metaphors the frameworks that will
apply to almost everything
then you might think in terms of what
you prioritize what do you uniquely
bring to the table what quirky
background and either academically or
what have you can you combine in ways to
have insights about solutions to
problems or areas of the world to focus
on that everyone else in the room isn't
also doing because it's those
interdisciplinary pairing of ideas I
think we're true meaningful
breakthroughs come through and that's
frankly I think we learn I think that's
a lot of excitement comes from and
that's what pushes the world forward
okay please 24 quick examples that just
made me think the sort of coo for Google
X whose name is Tom who has a lot of the
central teams under him these are people
like strategic sourcing these are people
gonna go she ate with our supply chain
and say hey like hey we'll give you a
million dollars if you'll like make this
totally weird thing that you've actually
never made before and then maybe if we
need it we'll get you know thousands of
them from you that person his background
is not finance he didn't work at
Mackenzie he was first in his class in
computer science at Oxford and the
person who was running we have the very
wide part of our funnel which is called
rapid eval team rapid evaluation team
which is all these sort of technical
polymaths when they graduate something
from their part of the organization when
they failed to kill it for the first
couple of months the place that it goes
next which is called the foundry is run
by a woman named OB and OB has no
technical background and yet all of the
things that were doing she actually was
running marketing for like about a third
of Google before she came to X and now
she's running a bunch of teams that are
doing incredibly technical things and
she is perfect for that you don't know
where you're going to end up and I think
it's these weird sore confluences of the
skills that you're picking up and the
experiences you're picking up and the
style that you have that will end up
determining where your best niches are
in life not what your major is one last
thing speaking they will set it practice
it it's an acquired skill everyone can
be a good speaker it's terrifying first
ten times just do it you'll get better
the other skill I might emphasize is
respect for cognitive diversity some
geeks like myself thought there is a
optimistic high energy
litical way of thinking about the world
whatever my cognis i was and that's
clearly right and everything on us is
deviant right and in my first few jobs i
really had a tough time with other ways
of thinking those people were all just
weirdos and once I started to embrace
that a team of five people plus or minus
two that are very different is going to
be better than a team of five experts to
think just like myself thank you for
that wonderful way of describing the
importance of diversity yeah um but as I
listened to you talk I get a little
worried that maybe domain expertise
isn't really needed um you're really
talking about those broader skills
learning how to learn but where does
domain expertise fit into this Christina
you want to take a shot at that I i
would say that i think um there is value
in domain expertise and that but really
what it is is that you from the context
of engineering innovation right i
believe that you have to have a good
understanding of the underlying
substrate that you're working with right
in order to apply you know in order to
innovate around it i think the point
that's being made which is also i would
agree with is that you know the
specifics right what is sort of
cutting-edge now is going to be obsolete
10 years from now right and so you have
to be able to continue to learn right
because you know if you just think about
biology right our models of things you
know 25 years ago or how I was taught
right genetics right is very different
than then what it would be like in a
genetics class now right just our
understanding of that substrate is very
different and the way that we understand
it and the way that we interface with it
and so you know if you want to continue
to sort of be at the forefront of a
field you have to be able you have to
have the plasticity to continue to learn
right and to continue to adapt and also
something that I think is challenging
for a lot of people it that was sort of
highlighted here is being able to move
between between disciplines right and
not necessarily only putting yourself
into one box right but being able to
move fluidly between them you both agree
with her yeah I might some reason my
list of my mind I think
sess learning and process knowledge ease
can become more and more important than
product knowledge that could be Stan
Shih ated in a database what do we know
about the world where the facts of the
world and the process learning how do we
accumulate wisdom how do we build
complex systems how do I learn over the
course of a career how do I succeed in
building a great team that kind of
iterative learning focusing on the
process variables the core label success
I think will be increasingly the locus
of learning yeah I would say maybe
ballpark sixty percent of the people we
hire we have some domain expertise that
we need them to have if we're building a
contact lens and we need
electrochemistry work done we're not
going to hire someone who doesn't have
an electrochemical background think that
doesn't make any sense but there are
lots of people who have electrochemistry
as part of their toolkit that really is
like table stakes for even for those
jobs and there are people who some of
whom don't actually have
electrochemistry as a major and still
have that as their expertise and all
told that's maybe sixty percent of who
we hire there's a lot of like sally is
amazing let's just get Sally because
like we're crazy if we don't have Sally
as part of our team and you know if
that's forty percent of everybody and
there's some of the other sixty percent
where you kind of didn't learn soccer
from the book you just ended up playing
a lot of soccer whatever you know how to
play soccer at the end of the day and
that's what we need great you're hired I
think people focusing on the domains for
any reason other than because you love
it is probably not going to get you what
you want so I'm going to just ask one
more question to the three of you and
then we're going to open it up to the
audience so I just want to put the
audience on notice that in a minute I'll
turn it over to you but at one last
question a lot of the technology Steve
that that that you fund Astro that you
develop Christina the potential
technology developing your lab there are
a lot of societal implications and some
of their not always positive
how responsible do you feel for the
societal implications of what you invent
and invest in and how what how do you
think about linking technology
innovation and societal responsibility
and you mama started off Steve sure um
it's a good question so in the in the
shortened immediate term you can be
responsible eyes saying oh yeah went to
certain categories you'll invest things
there's distasteful but the deeper
question is dangerously powerful
technologies which are all around us and
compounding dramatically as you know and
soon sort of the ultimate vector is
heading towards technologies that will
be trivial to execute as an undergrad
that could kill much of humanity for
almost no money and that you know in a
world that's a difficult world to
imagine the future so we as humans are
pretty static in terms of who we are our
culture evolves the last glacial pace
but sell some a glacial compared to all
these technology advances and so there
there can be a bit of a disconnect both
in terms of capabilities to do harm as
well as all kinds of ripples through
society so I believe technology is a
synonymous with progress it's kind of
like it's hard to detach progress in any
sense from advancement of ideas right
because I technology could be a
something like the scientific method
itself or a new form of governance
that's a form of technology but but most
of what we focus on are the technologies
that are accelerating dramatically and I
think it's a net-positive and almost all
fronts I think there's some really big
implications though as it rends the
fabric of society so we already see how
we live very differently today than 50
years ago culturally versus two thousand
years ago it's astounding how much
progress we've made and violence keeps
declining and our future might be bright
but I do worry about things like ever
accelerating rich-poor gap that might be
an inevitable byproduct of network
economies being part of most information
businesses and most businesses becoming
information-centric at the core at
different rates over time where they
just won't be jobs in agriculture there
were jobs driving cars which is about
twenty percent of paid employment today
that's all clearly going away in the
near term and all those new jobs come
and we'll all become information workers
and entertainment workers and
sounds great for except for people who
don't want to do that and it's all
globally competitive more than
regionally competitive and so you know
none of this will happen right away but
I think an extra bowl trend is that we
need to understand a world where that
will just keep accelerating not be self
rectifying but for perhaps policy but
for some waves in philanthropy which I
find encouraging that there's us a lot
of self-reinforcing feedback loops on
that so that's one thing I worry about I
don't know though what as an individual
and individual technology area could do
about it other than acknowledge the
larger trend that's an emergent
phenomena and say well there's a big
problem I could try to solve as an
entrepreneur let me think about that
future and let's say wow you want to
provide for basic human needs for
everyone when there no jobs well how
about Maslow's hockey needs food shelter
clothing health care and education if as
well as the what's alive today and let
me do it an app to write free health
care forever for everyone via smartphone
because like in the future we have to
have that or we'll be in trouble you
know it could be an entrepreneurial sort
of impetus to solve the problems that
are wringing our hands about it so
that's what I'm looking for as an
investor to say the technology's going
to do it does that's exhaust us we're
like the vessels for ideas and like a
genetic you know sort of bag if you will
we're also a medic bag and we spread
ideas promiscuous Lee and that's just
going to happen and we can't stop it so
how about tilting our efforts to
anticipating that future and helping a
transition be less cumbersome as it
currently seems to be correct Christina
um you know so somebody who develops
technologies right and and and thinks
about what technologies we want to
develop i omit so i think it's
definitely the case that as engineers we
have a responsibility to think about the
broader societal applications of the
technologies we develop this comes back
to part of it comes back to how do we
choose what to work on right i think
it's also the case you know and i run up
the run up against us a lot you know and
i think we have to acknowledge that
there's dual-use aspects of almost any
technology right i mean and many times
in ways that we can't even imagine write
a simple right example i mean did we
envision or imagine right that airplanes
would be used to sort of fly into
buildings right i mean that and and so
you have to end so you're not going to
be able to envision or even predict all
the ways that a technology might evolve
right
and all the ways that someone might take
a technology I think there are with many
technologies you can think about sort of
short term right or immediate how it
might be misused and then you can come
to some conclusion about whether you
think you know what is the basically
what are the pros and what are the cons
right rid of the trade-offs and is the
overall good worth the risk and then I
think what plays into it also is you
want to think about policy around it for
some potential risk for some potential
do you dual use there's a lot that we
can do working with regulators working
with government to think about policy
that can be developed to ensure that you
know as new technologies are introduced
we're mitigating you know what's
happening in other societies and making
sure that that's being minimized and
thinking again about the culture of how
we train our students so that we're
training right cadres of students and
engineers that are going to go forth and
you and and innovate and apply things
positively great Astro the final word on
that topic when we're working as
scientists as inventors as entrepreneurs
in any area obviously there's a
significant responsibility but that
responsibility can't be to control the
outcome of society that's not the job of
any of those people it's not necessarily
anyone's job but if it is anyone's job
it's the job of the public sector not
the private sector now that doesn't
waive all responsibility from those
people but it means that their
participation in the process is one of
transparency and education that means
participating with the public sector by
saying here's what we're working on
here's what we know about what it's
likely to be in the future you can help
or we can help you think through what we
might not know and maybe discover some
of those things ahead of time let's talk
about that I want to make sure you the
public sector understand as best as
possible and then that's your job not
our job to control this thing because
when we pursue any kind of technology
from a perspective of fear and secrecy
we are crippling it we are
turning it into something less than it
what it otherwise could have been and we
are seeding the real development of that
thing to the very people were most
afraid of so instead of painting these
technologies as the poster children for
our fears we should be accepting that
the world is changing and doing our job
as educator as educators to the public
sector of the ramifications of these
things but then continuing to move these
things forward without embarrassment
great all right let me now turn it over
and I think your handle is first up so
you get the first question so this is
this interesting idea that generational
privacy norms have have developed as a
result of say Facebook sharing photos
like you're talking about before and I
wanted to ask you to what extent do you
think technology drives our value system
and to what extent are the technologies
that you develop and fund a product of
the values you would like to foster and
I'm going to ask you to repeat I was
that directed at Steve or all three okay
so to keep it going we'll just have one
panelist answer so that we can get lots
of questions oh dear so maybe Steve but
yeah repeat the question because he's
not miked and this is being taped okay
so working backwards a part of her at
the end is to what extent though does a
value system infuse the investment
process who might go through and also
how does technology adjust perhaps our
values over times that was that the gist
of the first part of it hmm well the
second part let me start there because
it seems a bit more direct there are
absolutely as I lived to earlier
technologies that we think are for the
good of the world and and it's not just
that we feel better about our careers it
also tends to correlate with investment
success that if the company investment
is doing good a lot of good byproducts
follow like other people like the
company employees like the company
customers like it you know as opposed
the tobacco company or guns or something
so we tend not to invest in guns a long
list of things we tend not to investing
um but um the most anything that you
find in vegas for example is a simple
category um but the deeper thing is that
i've been struck by how some of the most
successful companies are purpose
in companies so planet labs was
mentioned Tesla you know in an opening
statement the Cutie report last year
setting a profits or not a priority as
the opening line of quarterly report and
the point was there's a higher mission
helped usher an arrow to electric
mobility and as that as the primary goal
there's a you know a sub goals you know
we're not going to lead the world to a
new era for not ourselves profitable and
attractive business so there are and
there many others like this google
arguably as a company like this facebook
arguably connecting the entire world is
the mission and we have but grudgingly
some revenue profits might have to come
along and suck realizes it's important
to you know carrying on so my point is
sort of sort of glib recanting is a
recasting of that is that that finding a
passionate entrepreneur the wants to
change the world for the better and
that's a value judgment is exactly what
we should be doing and that's also what
i try to do in my career is not just try
to maximize revenue or investment
potential anyone but what is going to
push the ball forward over a longer arc
of time which seems to make a more
resilient strategy i think our cultural
norms in juarez do shift over time I
think our circle of empathy continues to
expand and you look at entrepreneurship
itself as a bellwether of that which is
people used to think in the 20 years ago
about us companies in the US you know
serving us companies for us benefits now
it's clearly global in kc Elon Musk even
interplanetary let's help out you know
those future Martians I mean literally
that scope of emissions amazing and I
think in longer human history like the
you know the family unit the tribe the
city-state the nation-state the globe in
all sentient beings that seems to be how
our scope of empathy expands on
anything's largely by awareness
communication technologies that enable
this awareness and frankly the cultural
evolution that Cole valves with our
technological evolution so again 2000
years ago rape genocide and slavery
we're all fine according to mainstream
opinion pretty weird in certain cases
like warfare when you get to smoke
somebody that's when smoting is on their
menu then those things are fine so again
I'm glad about it but 2,000 years ago
humans were the same genetically we're
no different right I mean except for
some teeth and little swings and nothing
to do with her in our actual brains it's
it's cultural evolution and I think it's
largely infused by the inventions of
democracy the scientific method how do
we accumulate ideas over time and
discard
that are bad that's a form of Technology
so maybe the scientific method more than
anything else has accelerated the pace
of learning progress and betterment okay
next question yung Lee in the front row
process education is becoming more and
more important that we domain knowledge
for most people a lot of students when
they're graduating don't really know
where to find that so maybe end up in a
job like something or thinking or
somewhere where they pinch a lot of
beautiful maybe you don't get as much of
that as yourself to think if you were
graduating school now or advising
someone who word where would you
recommend going to get that process
education that's for the elastics I
wanna not repeat the question please I
will I feel I mean the question is if
we're not supposed to learn a skill like
computer science we're supposed to learn
these soft more transportable skills
that we've been mentioning up here but
that's exactly what you're taught anyway
doesn't say that on your resume the day
that you graduate where are you supposed
to go both to build those skills or
maybe to pick them up in the first place
that's your question the advice I give
to people independent of age is find
somewhere that you can be passionate
about surround yourself with people who
are at least as wonderful as you are who
are smarter than you and who you're
confident you can learn from more than
anything else find a manager who can be
your mentor I don't care if they're
making smelly soaps or trying to go to
Mars or something in between if you if
you maximize for those things where
you're around amazing human beings
trying to work really hard to do
something good for the rest of humanity
it's all going to work out you can't not
learn around those people you will
inevitably learn the skills that you
need and if you're in a place where the
mission and the types of people you're
around are draining your soul how are
you going to end up learning process
points like how to work in a group
you're going to try to avoid the people
you're around so i think that the things
that we wish were true happened to line
up with what's in your best interest in
this case which is to really be around
great people okay next question
just I mean for example hey yeah it's
from Tyler what what you said about the
responsibility for for the private
sector in terms of the implicate the
societal implications of your actions
the first thing on all three of you said
was what you need to do is need to
figure out how to change society's what
technical technology fundamentally does
so if that is your goal to change
society aren't you a little responsible
for how society changes as a result of
what you do doesn't that put more of a
pressure on you to see the impacts and
deal with them as they come up I think
so the question is if it's our goal to
change society or the world in some way
however well-intentioned our goal to
change the world is then doesn't that
add some incremental responsibility to
us in how the world ends up changing as
a result of what we build I think that's
a totally fair question I make two
points first of all while we sir I
certainly wouldn't use that to dodge the
responsibility if someone is making a
technology has no idea what it's going
to do in the world and is just gonna
throw it out there without an even a
goal to make the world better in some
particular way I can't see how that's
better from a moral perspective than
actually seeking to make the world a
better place so if you pick something
like let's say cars that can drive
themselves you need to work out early on
whether you believe in your heart
collectively that that's actually going
to make the world a better place now no
technology issues pointing out is an
absolute positive all technologies are
net positives or at least have the
potential to be net positives but none
of them are absolute positive so you
have to go through the math and say is
this a reasonable thing to do by the way
we probably throw out thirty percent of
our ideas purely on the basis that it's
a zero-sum game that we could make money
that it's not even necessarily bad for
the world but that it's not strictly
adding value to the world's just
shifting the value from someone else to
us and even that leaves
cold and we say nope not going to do
that one so we go through that process
but for example if just to use
self-driving cars there are going to be
people who have new jobs because cars
can drive themselves surely there going
to be some people who don't have jobs
anymore because cars can drive
themselves I'm compassionate about that
but a I'm not sure that that is
justifies 1.2 million people here dying
in car accidents that we would just
maintain the status quo of those jobs
because the fundamental problem I
believe is that we are failing the young
people of our societies around the world
we are not doing a good job of training
them and let's say in the limit we were
doing an abysmal job and it might not be
much better than that frankly of
training the young people of the world
to be really ready for the future what
should we do stop all forward progress
not cure any more diseases allow cars to
be as inefficient as they still are just
to make up for the public sector not
being able to educate people that seems
like the wrong solution to the problem
so I accept some responsibility but I
think the public sector and society at
large has to meet technologies
development halfway and take some
responsibility which it frankly does not
do a great job of doing but throws it
back at the doorstep of the changes that
technology causes even when those
technologies are aimed in in this
particular way I think an incredibly
well intentioned way maybe one last
question over there maybe you have it
doesn't en hope it because it is united
in because we can just copy paste is
right so can we try repeating that a
little bit more slowly and it's going
towards Christina right cause y'all say
that we do have a digital more 13
additional immortality yeah so at the
latest step in years from now right even
15 years and my question is that the end
of education as we know it because in 15
years we can just copy paste
philip ii get from the University person
is it the end of education we know that
you can upload our conscience to a
computer and why do we need to stop
learning then why no way why would that
follow but you gotta face ignorant ask
me how do you make that progress becomes
really because for example sick you
don't you supervise to basic to do bite
or two drivers for something right back
it's actually we can we can see no no we
can see from the brain how we can do it
and you can continue and do all
everything online you can just download
you don't need to go to school you just
read it off the computer so it's
basically why wont online education take
over everything no no that was you soon
no no just download it in your brain
like the major so like like I know
jiu-jitsu yes right like reality check
just because reycarts while believes and
transhumanism does not believe that
anybody else believes in that right like
just you're not wasting your time going
to school and I would be willing to bet
your grandkids are not going to be
wasting their time go schiphol can I can
actually I think it's actually an
important reason why that intuition
follows that when you grow a brain a
real brain or you create an equivalently
complex neural network or deep learning
algorithm the actual inner workings of
it are completely inscrutable it's only
really understand the woods interfaces
thing to do with a way in which those
algorithms work same is true for
evolution and the path dependence of how
we get to where we are so you can't even
though Jeff Hawkins at the end of his
book and on intelligence just out of
nowhere says we'll cut and paste like
French language skills or you know
between these are evolved artifacts I
don't think that's possible at all
because we have no example around us in
information networks rich complex
information networks where the evolved
product of biological evolution deep
learning machine learning any of these
is cut and paste the ball what is much
more efficient as just grow new one from
scratch and so you'll be learning more
than ever before just more rapidly okay
we are at the end of our time I want to
thank people for coming and I
should want to thank our speakers for
their very interesting insights
you